[Music]
gliding along the canal grande towards
the Venetian Lagoon within minutes the
scenery changes entirely the lagoon is
home to over 30 small islands most of
them uninhabited
after a half an hour we reach Murano
famous for its brightly colored
fisherman's houses local Sebastiano de
Rossi advises us to come early to avoid
the tourists he's the operator of a
travel portal and he tells us why the
houses here came to be painted in such i
popping shades the houses on Burano are
so colorful because the fishermen used
to be out at sea for long periods and
this way they could see their homes from
afar it made them less homesick gaza
these days the brightly painted houses
are such a big part of verrano's image
that owners must get permission to
change their color another eye catching
sight is the leaning bell tower of
burano which has a tilt of about 1.8
meters is there any sulphate sea but the
ground is very swampy and the church
tower was simply poorly planned by the
architect today we're quite proud of it
because it's become a landmark no one
can imagine Burano without the tower or
without its hand tattered lace these
types of floral patterns and textured
embroidery are typical of Burano lace
which enjoys a long tradition here today
just a few women still practice this
craft like this lace maker in a
specialty shop but hand tatted lace has
its price
like this tablecloth which took 20 lace
makers two years to make this clock is
approximately five by two meters it's
comprised of individual parts which have
been put together when folks ask how
much it costs we say as much as a
Ferrari and this wedding veil is
priceless it was once made for the
Italian royal family these days just a
few of the islands 2,500 residents live
from fishing they sell their catch in
Venice and to Bora knows numerous
restaurants their menus feature a wide
variety of fresh fish and seafood so
what's the locals favorite fish dish the
locals love marinated sardines in the
morning with a glass of wine that's
typical after lunch we set off for the
neighbouring island of Murano a
20-minute boat ride away Murano is world
famous for its glass in the 14th century
the island's glass blowers already had a
reputation as being the best of their
kind
Royals were among their customers today
Murano is still home to glass blowers
who are masters of their trade it takes
years of experience to know how to fuse
pieces of glass together so they won't
crack and to create certain colors
[Music]
[Music]
it's no secret that Murano glass is
known for its many colors to start off
the glass is almost black very dark but
we have a lot of experience and can
change the colors during the process to
make them lighter and more transparent
and to decide which colors suit which
object whether it's an elaborate
chandelier for thousands of euros or a
more affordable figurine most visitors
take home a souvenir made from Murano
glass actually we've got some friends
are getting married this year and we
thought maybe a wedding gift for them we
bought two pieces of glass two large
pieces of glass that they'll ship to us
next month yes we're very excited but
few tourists ever spend the night on
Burano or Murano with its breathtaking
scenery Venice is just too close and too
tempting
you